so here's
here's some of the new rules so
the first one is do not carelessly
denigrate social
institutions or creative achievement
i like i like that one because you're
more
prone to carelessly denigrate social
institutions if you're liberal
on the left side of the spectrum let's
say because
you're interested in lateral thinking
and spontaneity and
and novelty and um
leery of of what would you say
structures that constrain
and then if you're more on the
center or the right you're more likely
to denigrate creative achievement
because
while the creative types you know
they're always moving laterally and
breaking things apart and i mean i mean
the genuinely creative types you know
the ones who are on the avant-garde and
they're a bit of a threat to social
institutions but
the truth of the matter is that you need
both there's a there's this old
there's this line in ellis in wonderland
when ellis goes down the rabbit hole
underneath the structure of things and
she meets the red queen down there
red queen is basically mother nature and
she's red because
mother nature is red in blood you know
that's why the red queen is always
running around yelling off with their
heads you know she's
she's the queen of mayhem and murder and
one of the things she says is that in my
kingdom you have to run as fast as you
can just to stay in the same place
and that's really set that's the
fundamental
flaw of rigid conservatism
is that you cannot stay in the same
place because everything around you
shifts and so you're forced to update
and so eve
if you're a conservative person you
can't denigrate creative achievement
because
a certain amount of it is necessary just
to keep things stable
and if you're a conservative you're
interested in stability you think well i
wish things could stay the same
it's like nope not gonna happen
you know i mean you don't even stay the
same right you sit there and you think
i'm just gonna stay the same
and and you don't you get old and and it
right right i mean it just happens and
because of that you have to
you have to update and it's the creative
types that do the updating now you know
that can get out of hand and things can
you know you can get so many people
creative people destabilizing this the
the current situation so that nothing is
reliable and that that that untrammeled
creativity can be a destructive force
that's its danger but it's necessary
to respect cultural institutions and
also to respect the process that
updates them and so that's what that
chapter is about
and so imagine who you could be and then
aim single-mindedly at that
see i like that one the single-mindedly
part is
an interesting one what i learned this
at least in part from nietzsche is you
know when you're a kid
in principle you could be anything which
is kind of one of the wonderful things
about being a kid
and then one of the painful things about
growing up and being an adult is that
well you can't just stay being
everything
that's the story of peter pan right pan
means everything
and peter pan is this magical child
you know who can do anything but
he's just he's got a strange kingdom
right he's king of the lost boys
which perhaps isn't the kingdom that you
want to rule over
and and so and he doesn't grow up
and so he falls in love with wendy and
wendy grows up and she has a family she
gets old
she stops being a child but she has a
family she has a husband
she has a family she has a life and
peter pan just stays in neverland which
is also a hint on the part of the reader
and he stays magical and contents
himself with tinkerbell who i always
think of her as the porn fairy
and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah he's got all the advantages of
femininity except she's not real
[Applause]
yeah and so you know peter pan he
doesn't want to grow up partly because
his role model is captain hook and
captain hook
well you think about he's a pirate so
he's kind of a tyrant
and he's also a coward and he's a coward
because he's
well he's afraid at least because he's
being chased by a crocodile with a clock
in his stomach
you think what the hell does that mean
he's being chased by a crockett what
does that mean it's like well
and it's already got a piece of him
right it's bitten off his hand it liked
the taste
well it's time that's why the clock is
there
you know it's time and the crocodile is
the terrible force that lies underneath
everything that waits to pull you down
like it's mortality itself and the
threat of mortality and the reason that
captain hook is a tyrant is because he's
afraid of death
and so that makes him a tyrant and a
cowardly tyrant and peter pan looks at
the cowardly tyrant and he thinks well i
don't want to grow up to be that
and it's like well fair enough you know
but what are you gonna do not grow up
well then you stay king of the lost boys
and you have tinkerbell and
life goes on and that's not a good
outcome and so
you know you have to make a sacrifice
when you grow up
you have to become something and to
become something means to not become a
whole bunch of other things like it's
a sacrifice it's the same sacrifice that
you undertake when you decide to get
married
you know it's like well you forego
everyone else
to have one person and and it
and it isn't it's a real sacrifice and
it's a sacrifice that prays on people's
minds because they think well you know
maybe i could have picked someone better
it's like
because you always suffer from the
delusion that someone better would have
agreed to have you and well it's funny
i just i just read this this great
article i tweeted it a couple of nights
ago i read this great article about how
people
select potential mates on dating sites
and they
they you people generally go for those
who are about 25
more attractive than they are so which
is you know ambitious
and and and pointless um
but that is what people do you know they
hope that me by what they hope they hope
the person won't notice
it's like i just i'll just slip myself
in here and maybe you won't notice
it's like
well so there's a sacrifice you know and
but the thing about the sacrifice is
that
you end up with something rather than
nothing at all and i've seen lots of
people in my clinical practice you know
who didn't grow up when they should have
and
and who are 30 or which isn't too bad
although it's not that good
but 40 you know they're still drifting
they still haven't
catalyzed an identity of any sort and
that gets that starts to get ugly you
know 30
it starts to get ugly around 30. if
you're 23 or 24 and you haven't
catalyzed an identity
it's okay people think well you're
mostly peter pan you're full of
potential man
will gamble on the potential you know
and take a chance at you but then if
you're 30
and you have the same non-existent
resume
people think well you just failed
it's not potential it's just you're just
not there and if it's
that's the case at 40 that's getting
really rough like it's not completely
hopeless if you're in that situation at
40 but
man you've got a lot of catching up to
do and so
and so how do you get out of that well
partly and this is one of the things
you also have to let young people know
is pick something
you don't know what to do well take your
best damn shot at it
don't wait around man make a plan aim at
something
move in that direction adopt a
disciplinary routine of some sort
because that will that will that will
form you now it limits you too but it
forms you and then
you know and then the thing about
adopting a disciplinary
structure which limits you and which is
a sacrifice is that
it also it also increases the
probability that you're going to do
something
useful over the long run you know
when i was starting out as a researcher
my area of research was somewhat narrow
i was looking at the heredit i was
looking at factors that influenced
the inheritability of alcoholism because
alcoholism is heritable to a large
degree
and it's partly because the manner in
which you respond to a drug of abuse
is determined in part by biological
factors
and that the variance in those
biological factors is
biologically determined to a fair degree
so
i'll give you an example i had this
friend his name was frank irvin
he was a very cool guy he looked like
ernest hemingway and a big beard and he
was a cool character and he had this
ranch in saint kitts it was a monkey
ranch
i know i know a monkey ranch and he was
raising
alcoholic monkeys and because he was a
researcher and
and he would take these wild monkeys
green monkeys
and and bring them in to an enclosure
and then he would give them rum and coke
and five percent of the monkeys would
drink tacoma on first exposure
and he had videotapes of that which were
really hilarious they looked like
they looked like frat party
fundamentally
you know and most of the monkeys would
have a few sips and you know and and
just discuss their monkey
business in in
you know in a civilized way in a corner
and then go home
you know when when it was time to call
it a night but there was five percent of
them and they were like
hanging off the trees by their tail in
their arms by the end of the evening and
and passed out completely anyways one of
his discoveries was that in in a wild
population
of primates who were relatively naive to
alcohol
that if you expose a certain proportion
of them five percent of them had no
control whatsoever over their
drinking they just drink great tacoma
that's about the same with
with people who start to experiment with
alcohol so anyways that's one of the
examples that
you know that there was there was there
was a biological influence anyways
this area of inquiry was somewhat
narrower than i had
hoped for you know i didn't really i
hadn't really planned on studying the
psychobiology of response to alcohol i
was interested in drug abuse and drug
abuse motivation i was interested in
wider issues but
what was so cool was that the deeper i
got into that so the more i disciplined
myself with regards to that particular
domain of study the more i learned about
all sorts of other things it was like
going through a
keyhole and then out the other side and
most disciplinary
processes are like that and so one of
the things you have to do is
you take the plury potentiality of
childhood and you discipline that
so that that might be a meta rule like
you couldn't say well here's the
disciplinary structure
everyone should undertake that's too
specific a rule
you know everybody should go into the
military it's like no not necessarily
who knows what your disciplinary
strategy should be but i you can make a
more abstract rule which is something
like
i don't care what your disciplinary
strategy is
but you need to impose one on yourself
and for some reasonable amount of time
because you integrate yourself as a
consequence of doing that
as well as making yourself you know
vaguely socially useful and appropriate
which is also a non-trivial thing
and then once you have yourself
disciplined then you can take that
discipline stealth and you can start
expanding it outward again
and so that's a really useful thing to
know so this is
nietzsche who is a great criticism great
critic of christianity
was an admirer of catholicism um
interestingly enough because one of the
things he
believed was that the attempt
over several thousands of years to
force every phenomenon
into a framework that could be explained
by the axioms of catholic belief
disciplined the european mind it made it
it made it capable of producing rigorous
and coherent theories independent of
whether the theory was correct that
wasn't the issue it was like well
once you learn how to write you can
write saa but you could also write sab
if you don't know how to write you can't
write either you know maybe you learn to
write by writing essay a but then you
can write essay b
and c and the same issue applies here is
once you get yourself disciplined
then you can take the disciplined self
and you can go do a bunch of different
things with it
and so maybe it doesn't matter how you
discipline yourself
but it really matters that you do and so
that's an important thing i think i
think it's an important thing for
everyone to know but i think it's really
an important thing for young people to
know it's like well i don't know what to
do with myself
well don't sit around and get old that's
a bad idea
and spin around doing nothing it's like
pick something
make a mistake right pick something that
you're not sure about and go and pursue
it
you get a quarter of the way there
halfway there you're a lot smarter
because you've had to
undertake a fair bit of learning just to
get that far maybe at that point you
find out it's not for you
and you decide to make a left hand turn
you know you make a 90 degree turn
somewhere else
at least you've fleshed yourself out in
the pursuit of the discipline
and don't wait around you know and i
think that's
well so that's what that chapter is
about and so
yeah and then rule three is analogous to
that work as hard as you can
as you possibly can on at least one
thing and see what happens well
it is a corollary to that it's like well
one of the things you want to discover
when you're young
or one of the things you want to
discover at some point in your life
it's better to discover when you're in
your 20s i think is well just how hard
can you work on something
you know like if you pick something i
don't care what it is again you think
i'm going to go flat
out on this and see what happens
and that's also useful too because
there's no other way of really
discovering your limits
right and you kind of want to know what
your limits are i think one of the
things you need to do in your life at
some point is push yourself
farther than you can go you know so you
kind of push yourself
past the point of exhaustion think oh
that's good
there's the point of exhaustion well you
can't stay there because if you stay at
the point of exhaustion for any length
of time well then you know you'll you'll
degenerate right because
that that's just too much but you can
find that point and then you can pull
back and you can think okay well i can't
go farther than that i
i kind of know where my limit is now i
can pull back and i can operate within
that limit
but then at least you know where your
limit is and that's an unbelievably
useful thing to do
as well and the other thing too is it's
like well how are you ever going to
discover
if you could possibly be successful at
whatever you want to be successful at
unless you push yourself in at least one
direction
right to your bloody limit and it's
another thing you know it's another
thing
we don't teach young people and it's
quite striking to me because it seems
kind of obvious it's like well
who are you you're 19 you're 20. who are
you well you don't bloody know
how do you know it's like six years ago
you were 13.
you don't know anything so well so what
are you capable of
well you don't know well how are you
going to find out well you're going to
push yourself
at something farther than you can go
and then you have some sense of where
your limits are and you know your limits
are going to be
they're not going to be where you think
they are all probability well some of
them will be a little closer than you
want them to be but a lot of them you'll
be able to push yourself way farther
than you think
and so that's that's an unbelievably
useful thing to do
and so that's you and then maybe you
know if you really want to get ambitious
about it you could push yourself
as far as you could go in five or six
different directions and just find out
like well where are your contours you
know
what what it what exactly are the
limitations of this form that you're
inhabiting
and you get some sense of who you are
and what you're good for
you know and that's a lot this is part
of the reason why i'm not happy with
this
continual injunction in our society to
well to have more self-esteem or to be
happy
it's like well first of all good luck
with being happy and
well it's just not going to work out
when you're not happy
you know and things are going to come
along that are going to make you not
happy
and then if the whole purpose of being
is to be happy and you're not happy then
as soon as you're suffering you're done
because you got nothing you certainly
don't have happiness and that's all
there was
that was the whole point and it's gone
because you're suffering you've got
nothing
that's not a use that's not useful but
you know
didn't it that's not to say that i have
anything against happiness if it happens
to come along
you know well you know you got to be
grateful if it does come along but
you can't rely on it that's for sure
that that's
that's foolish but you know you could
inform young people that they have to
figure out
just exactly how capable and resilient
they are and that
the way they do that is by by testing
themselves against
against severe challenges you know
voluntarily
we know that from from our from clinical
practice
from clinical sciences well how do you
make people resilient it's well that's
easy you
identify a set of challenges that they
need to undertake and you know you kind
of match the challenge to the person
like you would for a child that you care
for and you say well why don't you
you know see if you can withstand this
challenge go take it on
and the person goes and gives it a shot
and finds out well yeah i can do it it's
like great
you're tougher than you thought you were
so here's here's a slightly larger
challenge why don't you go
check out that and see if you can do it
too and you know your ability expands as
you take on the challenges
that's how you make people resilient you
know bloody well put them in safe spaces
and
and what shield them from
microaggressions
you know
i think you only you only do that if you
want to make people weak enough so that
you can make them weak enough so that
your ideological
what would you call it the ideological
formulation
of victimization and oppression can find
a ready target so you take university
students yeah you that's it
you make them as weak as possible and as
frightened and timid as they can be
and then they're hungry consumers of
your pathological ideology
that's that's a hell of a thing to do to
young people man and it's
and it's so interesting because it's
interesting because
it is exactly the opposite of what you
will do
with people if you're a clinician who's
properly trained
and you want to help people become
stronger and you know there's like 10
different variants of clinical
psychologies
behaviorism and phenomenology and
existentialism and humanism and
psychoanalysis there's lots of different
schools of psychotherapy
but all the well-developed schools of
psychotherapy
do share at least one thing in common
and that is that
you help people confront things they're
afraid of and that they're avoiding
and that that makes them stronger like
that's that's the fundamental essence of
successful psychotherapy and it's and
the reason for that is because that's
the fundamental essence of learning
so actually what you're trying to do if
you're it's not like psychotherapists
invented how to make people resilient
obviously not
what they did was observe what made
people resilient and formalize it what
makes people resilient is
for them to push themselves up against
challenges
and become stronger as a consequence of
it and so
it's so interesting to see that this has
been inverted
in in the universities it's actually
been turned upside down
and equally interesting to see that the
that the clinical bodies like the
american psychological association
cursed be their name and the american
psychiatric association haven't come out
on moss and said
look you couldn't
do anything more
malevolent to young people if you
planned it than to shield them from all
voluntary contact with things that
challenge their beliefs
right it's the worst thing you could do
so i can't believe i can't believe that
they organize
it's hard for me to believe that the
organizations have been that cowardly
but but there it is
they are so that's that's life um
rule four do not hide unwanted things in
the fog
yeah that's a good one
you know how it is when when something's
up and you don't want to think about it
christ that's probably you know you
sometimes that's your whole life
it's like it's like god something's up i
don't want to think about it i don't
want to think about it
well that that whole that's interesting
that you could not want to think about
something
because you this is this is this is what
tangled freud up at sigmund freud up in
the idea of repression
because he kind of thought that you knew
what it was that you didn't think about
and then you decided that you weren't
going to think about it
which is very paradoxical because then
you have to know and not know at the
same time
and that isn't actually how it works
it's more complicated than that
you know let's say that you come home
from work and you're in a bad mood
and that happens right and um
you know your wife or your husband or
your child or your dog
does something that's minor league
annoying
and you get all upset about it and while
your dog doesn't ask you it still likes
you but
your your your wife or your kid might
say well you know what's up with you
particularly your wife is likely to say
that or your husband what's up with you
you know like you're overreacting i'm
not overreacting it's like well you're
crabby about something i'm not crabby
about anything
it's like yeah you are what are you
crabby about well you don't know
well this is an interesting thing you
know that that something can upset you
and you actually don't know what it is
and then you know if you're fortunate
the person that you're with will torture
you a bunch
and make you figure out what you're
crabby about
and you won't be happy about that you
know and sometimes that'll actually
result in tears
even when you realize what it is that
that's upsetting you
and who the hell wants to go through
that nobody and so you know you just
avoid that
but but it's not a good idea what you
want to do is you want to take what
you're upset about
this is partly what you do in
psychotherapy so people come
to you as a therapist and they're upset
and you want to figure
out what they're upset about and so you
say well what might you be upset about
you know and then they guess and it's
like
i like to think about it as laying car
like maybe the person's got a deck two
decks of cards in their hand
and they're laying all the cards out on
the table you know that's a metaphor you
lay your cards out on the table
and so that's what you do with someone
you so the person comes to therapy
because things aren't going for them the
way
that they would like them to go because
otherwise why would they be there
and but it isn't necessarily obvious why
and so what you have to do is listen a
bunch is like
what's your problem what do you think
your problem is well i don't really know
but i'm not happy well what might your
problem be
let's guess at it stupidly wander around
a bit
you know it's like doing a bad first
draft it's the same thing well maybe
it's this i might be upset about this or
i might be upset about this or i might
be upset about what happened to me when
i was a kid or
you know or i'm upset at work or you
know i'm not happy with my kids or i'm
not happy with my wife i'm not happy
with myself or like
you know there's all sorts of reasons
you might be upset and what what you
find if you do that with people you let
them wander through
the domain of being upset
is that they come out with 30 things
they might be upset about but almost
right away they can figure out that 15
of those things or 20 of those things
are irrelevant
they can take them off the table but
they can't take them off the table till
they've laid them on the table
until they've until they've walked
through it you know and that's part of
that the part of the pro that's part of
the process
by which emotion becomes articulated
because your emotions will signal to you
that something's wrong
but they won't tell you why because
emotions aren't very high resolution
so you're crabby you know because maybe
your boss makes an offhand comment made
an offhand comment two weeks ago
and some part of you thinks that maybe a
promotion that you deserved is now not
in the works
but you didn't even really notice that
you know it it got you
it wasn't it wasn't the response you
wanted from your boss
and so god only knows what it signifies
and it it sets your mood sideways and
then it makes you susceptible to
outbursts at home
it's very difficult to dig down into
that and you know you might have to
admit to yourself that you really want
the that you really want the uh
promotion and maybe you have to admit
that well you haven't done everything
you possibly could to deserve it and
maybe you'd have to dig into the fact
that your relationship with your boss
isn't everything it could be and then
you'd have to figure out that you're not
working as hard at work
as you might because you're resentful
it's like jesus it's just a bloody
morass down there you know
and you see this with couples who are on
the verge of divorce
i they can't talk
because everything they say is a
minefield you know and it's a minefield
that
so every topic is associated with the
same discussion
that's occurred repeatedly for the last
20 years and never been sorted out
and so every single sentence is a
minefield
and then you dig into that you find that
there's like
behind underneath each contentious
sentence that's when you have people
sitting there
you know in your office with their arms
crossed and every time one of them says
something the other one rolls their eyes
and by the way that's a good predictor
of divorce
i'm dead serious if you want a predictor
of divorce it's like your your husband
your wife talks you roll your eyes it's
like you guys
you're done that's that's contempt
you know and once the contempt settles
in it's very very difficult to reverse
it
and the contempt doesn't settle in if
there hasn't been
10 000 hours of non-communicative fights
and that's partly that wish that people
can hide things in the fog
it's like i'm upset and i bloody well
don't know want to know why
and it's no wonder and so the freudian
repression idea is wrong it's because
you don't
know what it is that's upsetting you and
then you
refuse to face it it's more subtle than
that is that
your emotions hint at you that something
isn't the way it should be and then you
you can you can remain unconscious
merely by not attending to that
i think i don't want to i don't want to
think about that it's like yeah well no
wonder but
what are you going to do you're going to
wait you're going to collect all these
errors around you right an immense
number of unsolved errors you do that
long enough and your whole life is just
a
morass of unsolved errors and then you
really won't want to think about it
and then you're really done and so well
what's the rule
don't hide unwanted things in the fog
well you know
imagine that you're wandering through
the fog and there's and there's
there's pits that you could fall into
and that there's there's knives that you
could impale yourself on there's sharp
edges everywhere
it's like well that's terrible the
world's it's terrible that the world is
full of pits and sharp edges and knives
hidden in the fog it's like well yeah
but what if you disperse the fog
well then the pits are still there and
so are the sharp edges and the knives
but
you don't have to fall into them because
you can just walk around them
you know and that that's another reason
why it's so useful to face things it's
like well
if you if you if you become articulate
about what it is that's disturbing you
then you sharpen up you sharpen up your
representations of the catastrophe let's
say
and then you can then you can it turns
out that it's
much more probable that you can deal
with it you know and you can't be sure
because sometimes
you're just screwed you know and well
that's why you end up
dying right it's like well i'm dead
serious about this i don't want to be
you know i don't want to be stupidly
optimistic sometimes you can be backed
into a corner and there's no escape
that happens but most of the time it's
not the case most of the time if you
if you if you're willing to make the
situation
clear right which is a matter of facing
it
and then clarifying it it's a courageous
thing to do that's to beard the dragon
in its den you know if you do that then
you find that the situation resolves
into a set of problems that
are smaller than you originally assumed
they would be
and there's a much higher probability
that you can decompose the problems and
then start to address them
and it doesn't matter because it's it's
your best bet
like even if it doesn't work and it
might not it's like you don't have a
better strategy there is not a better
strategy
there's not a better strategy than to
seek out the dragon in its debt
even though there's some possibility
that you'll get burnt to a crisp and
that you won't get the gold
it's much better than waiting at home in
your bed quivering while the thing grows
and comes in and eats you
because then for sure you lose and
that's pretty much how life works
so that's what that chapter's about
[Applause]
i'm gonna read the rest of these because
i'm not going to get through all them
but i can at least let you know what
they are
rule five abandon ideology
rule six this is the one i've just been
working on this one just about killed me
it's very very difficult was writing was
very difficult to write this
this is a cool one notice that
opportunity lurks where responsibility
has been abdicated
i'm going to return to that one because
that's such a
strange thing to to learn do not do
things that you hate
that's a variant and i wrote a rule in
in the first book
which was tell the truth or at least
don't lie
and i formulated it that way because
well you don't know how to tell the
truth because what the hell do you know
and
but you you can maybe not lie because
sometimes you know you're going to say
something
and you know it's a lie and you can just
not lie
and sometimes you just don't know and
well then
you know you're ignorant and that's
irreducible in some
sense but so maybe you can't tell the
truth because you don't know the truth
but you can
not lie and this is the behavioral
equivalent of this
you know because you shouldn't do things
that you hate
it's the same as lying it's just it's
the acting out of a lie
think well i have to do things that i
hate it's like well
don't be so sure about that or maybe you
have an ethical
doesn't maybe maybe that's not a good
enough reason maybe you have an ethical
obligation
to not do things you hate the same way
that you have an ethical obligation not
to lie
and the excuse well i had to do it's not
it
it might even be it might even be valid
in some sense because you can find
yourself in situations
where you're terribly constrained the
problem is it's not helpful
you know it lies will come back to haunt
you
and the same thing happens when you do
things that you hate it's the behavioral
equivalent of a lie it will absolutely
come back to haunt you and if
you're in a situation where you're
required to do that for whatever reason
well
that's terrible for you and and maybe
there's no way out of it or no simple
way out of it but
you're gonna you're gonna be punished
for it and not least by yourself
not least by the degeneration of your
character which is a terrible thing
because you actually need your character
in order to survive
right your character is the strength
that you have to bring to bear in the
world
and if you compromise that well then you
will absolutely pay for that
so
try to make one room in your house as
beautiful as possible
that's a fun one because it's very
beauty it is a bit of a meditation on
beauty you know
beauty is a mysterious thing it isn't
obvious
what it is or why it's valuable and it's
kind of an intimidating thing you know
because
well because we're all flawed and so if
we encounter something beautiful then
you know it it's it's
in some sense to encounter something
beautiful is also to become aware of
all the ways that you're not that and so
it's too
it's too it's to dare to to encounter an
ideal
that shames you i would say and it's
partly why people are afraid of beauty
but
beauty is also a window into i don't
know exactly it's a window into
something transcendent
you know i think most people experience
this directly when they listen to music
because most people like music and you
know we might differ
in what music we consider beautiful but
virtually everyone has a genre that
speaks to them
of something that's beautiful and and
there's something intensely meaningful
and sustaining about that and
you know so this rule is about well
attempting to do something like that in
your own life you know you can take a
little corner
if it's not a whole room because the
first
suggestion i had i didn't write this as
a rule but it's become a
rather popular meme as to you know to
clean up your room
put your room in order maybe before you
try to put the world in order
that would be a good thing put your room
in order but maybe after you put your
room in order you try to make it
beautiful because that's that's the next
step of elevation is
could you take something that's merely
organized and functional and elevated to
the next level
could you dare to interact with with
something that's beautiful could you
reach that high and
you know that transforms your life
that's why art transforms people's lives
because
a a great piece of art is like a portal
through which beauty pours and it can
pour
over everything it's a terrifying thing
i had a good artist freddie said well
that's why we put frames around
paintings is to keep the beauty stuck in
the painting because you don't
want it leaking out all over the house
and causing trouble
you know it's bad enough that it's right
there in front of you
telling you how things could be but
aren't stating
to you that there's much more work to do
that you're not doing
and that everything is far more worth
attending to than you have the time to
attend to
the great painting does that you know
maybe
maybe you think of an impressionist who
goes out and paints a
like a haystack i think that was monet
who painted all the haystacks
never remember if it's monet or manet
doesn't matter he painted these
no it might have mattered to him but it
doesn't matter to this story
he painted all these haystacks under
different conditions of light you know
and and they're very different in color
you think well you might think
if you're not very sophisticated why
would someone paint the same haystack
over and over and
the answer that was if you think it's
the same haystack you're not paying any
attention because it's unbelievably
different
you know and most of the time we only
have a chance to glance at something but
an artist will
look at something that you'd only glance
at and look at it and look at it and
look at it and work on it and represent
it and
then that reminds you when you look at
it reminds you that everything is worth
looking at deeply even though you don't
have the time to do it
and it's a it's a window into the
the realm of reality that's outside of
your casual glance
and it connects you with that and so if
you dare to
if you dare to engage with beauty then
it serves as a reminder that you're
connected to something that's beyond
your comprehension
all the time and that's a good thing to
know it's in some sense it's like
in some sense it's like letting god into
your life you know
and that's why beauty is a window into
the divine and i think that's literally
true well maybe you have a better
explanation for beauty it's not an easy
thing to explain
you know it it's not an easy thing to
explain the fact that it beckons and
that it's attractive then it's
terrifying
and challenging all at the same time
it's like what is it what is it that's
lurking
in there that has that effect you know
it's definitely something that's beyond
the mundane you know by definition and
it's something
to set up something in your house that's
beyond the mundane that beckons to you
you know
it's a daring thing to do and people are
terrified of it and so they won't do it
and it's no wonder
but but it's a great thing to dare
rule nine is if old memories still make
you cry write them down carefully and
completely
that's a good one if something's
bothering you from the past and you
think about it still makes you upset
part of you stuck back there there's
there's part of your soul that's stuck
back there and you need it
in the present you're lesser than you
should be and the fact that those
memories still contain
emotion is an indication that that part
of your experience has not been
sufficiently articulated and that you
have
not been freed from the past so that's a
useful thing to know
18 months is about a good rule of thumb
and there's actually neurological
reasons for that
so if something's plaguing you those
will be often memories that recur
sometimes there are nightmares that
recur if it's plaguing you if it comes
back up this still bothers me
well then you're you're you're you're
stuck in the past there's part of you
there's part of there's no better way of
putting it than that there's part of
your soul that's stuck in the past
and you need to rescue it you need to
bring it up to the present because
life is demanding enough so that it
takes all of you
here and now to deal with it properly
and if you're stuck in the past then
you're weaker than you
then you have to be and you'll pay for
that
but if you write them down if you write
the memories down if you
thoroughly assess them and analyze them
try to understand what went wrong and
how that might
not be duplicated in the future and you
can
i'll tell you a story then maybe i'll
stop with this i'd like to read the rest
of these rules
plan and work diligently
plan and work diligently to maintain the
romance in your relationship
that's a good one it's a funny one the
way because
the first part of that sentence is a lot
different than the second part
plan and work diligently okay that's
sort of one conception
that's for sure one conceptual realm to
maintain the romance in your
relationship it's like no those things
don't go together
you know but they do they do as a
clinical psychologist
you know i often encourage my clients to
date their wife or husband have a date
we're not getting along it's like when
was the last time you
you did anything romantic together it
was like a year ago it's like
really really that might be
one of the reasons you're not getting
along
or maybe it's a symptom of the fact that
you're not getting along well do you
do you go out with each other well we
don't have the time well fair enough you
know
you know life you life gets in the way
you know if you're
you both have a job and you have little
kids it's you know maybe have some other
responsibilities it's very easy for the
romantic part of your relationship to
fall to priority 11 on a list of one to
ten and
you never get to it you know and so then
i would tell my clients well what are
you
what do you go on a date you know and
they're one sitting there and one's
sitting there they won't have anything
to do with each other
and the first thing they think is i wish
we would have gone and seen a different
therapist
and then the next thing they think is
okay
we'll do it but we'll do it grudgingly
and we're not going to enjoy it
and that'll show you that you're wrong
and so
then they come back and you know maybe
they went to a movie and i said well
how'd it go they said well we had a
terrible time
we had a terrible time we couldn't agree
on the movie and then we went to the
movie and we just fought afterwards and
we went to a lousy little restaurant and
it was a wretched
we had a wretched time and we're never
doing that again and then they
look at me like they're victorious you
know and i think
[Laughter]
i think oh i see that's your theory
you're never going to do that again
that's your solution to the lack of
romance in your relationship
it's like well of course you're not very
good at it you're stuck with this person
so it's like maybe you go on 10 dates
and like
the first one is 100 wretched and the
next one is only 95
wretched and so that's a really good
trajectory you know
because by the time you get to the 15th
date maybe you can sort of tolerate each
other again
and if you did it 30 times well maybe
you'd be halfways good at it and if
you're going to be married for 50 years
you might as well put the effort into it
have 30
wretched married dates so that you can
get good at it
you know
you know and you don't think about it
because people are they're sort of naive
and arrogant at the same time
well we should be able to just go out
and have a romantic time it's like
really you should just be able to do
this like what makes you
think that you're good at that you know
it's like
if you're 16 and you know and your your
hormones are
raging and you have absolutely no
experience whatsoever
and you go out on a date like maybe
it'll be roma probably it won't probably
be just bloody wretched and horrible but
it might be romantic and wonderful and
then maybe you'll remember that for the
rest of your life but i mean that's a
very strange concatenation of
of ignorance naivety and and and
overwhelming hormonal influence it's
like it's not you
it's it's just something that happened
to you and the romance in a relationship
that's long term is an
art it has to be fostered it has to be
invested in
you know and and people don't like to
think that because you think well
sex should be spontaneous it's like yeah
good luck with that
you know it's like maybe no it's
forget it it's not over the long run
you have to make time you know and if
when you're first trying to
what impress someone that you might
want to sleep with or have a
relationship with you're willing to put
the time and effort into it
you know so why wouldn't you do the same
thing with the person that you're gonna
live with for the rest of your life
so why wouldn't you think of that as
something that's a necessary investment
the rule of thumb that i've discovered
just two of them
is you want to have a successful
long-term relationship
one is you got to talk to each other for
90 minutes a week
that's really painful that whole
conversation it's like well
what have you been up to and what have i
been up to and what am i worried about
and what am i thinking about it's like
i've got a narrative of my life and
you've got one and we have to string
them together
that takes about 90 minutes a week of
just some of that's just practical
communication too about what has to
happen in the household what has to
happen with the kids and what's going on
with the career and
why the car needs to be fixed you know
just the mundane realities of the
domestic economy
that has to be discussed and you need 90
minutes of that or you fall behind
and you get separated and then you need
the same amount of time
devoted to something approximating
intimacy and romance and
that should be made into an art and it
requires
effort and work it's not spontaneous
like maybe if you get really good at it
you know if you watch great ballroom
dancers or
their actions look spontaneous it's like
yeah well they practiced
ten thousand dollars before they got to
be expert at it and
why would you assume that
you were a law ethereal without putting
in the effort you know
it's not an easy thing to keep that
spark
alive and vital across decades you have
to be awake and careful and you have to
make it a priority
and so there is that planning and
diligent work and it's
worthwhile thinking it's like what do
you want you want you want a life
without romance it's like how much
pleasure is there in life
you know there's a handful of pleasures
that's all
and they're they're easily forgone and
then they're gone
better to plan and work diligently to
maintain them
i'll read you the other
all right rule 11
be grateful in spite of your suffering
and rule 12
do not allow yourself to become
resentful deceitful or arrogant
i'll tell you a story about being stuck
in the past it's quite interesting
i i know this man who was very badly
abused when he was a child
really in a horrific manner and uh he
told me
at one point that he's about 50. he said
he hadn't looked in the mirror for 35
years
because he couldn't stand looking at
himself and so
35 years and then he was having these
dreams
about the abuse and in the dreams he was
still five years old
and being abused and so i told him you
gotta look in the mirror
because you don't know how old you are
you have to look he's
hiding things in the fog and it's no
bloody wonder
i'll tell you if you went through what
he went through you would hide them in
the fog too
but doesn't matter because it happened
it has to be dealt with
and so he looked in the mirror for an
hour i said you look in the mirror for
an hour and he said he did that it made
him cry
he didn't know he was old it was a shock
to him you know
but he said it was really useful and and
it made him sad but it also made him
happy at the same time he experienced
all sorts of emotions
you know and so and then
i also told him okay so you're having
these terrible dreams about being abused
so you have to look in the mirror
because
you don't know how old you are there's a
party that doesn't know how old you are
and so in the dream you're still
five and you're still a victim you're
still a five-year-old victim but you're
not five man you're 50. it's like
that needs to be updated that's not
happening to you anymore because you're
a different person
but part of you doesn't know it so you
got to look at yourself even though
that's a horrifying thing to do
you look at yourself i said well when
you have the dream it's terrible
nightmare you wake up and then what you
do is you think about that nightmare you
relive it
that's another therapeutic technique if
you're trying to help someone get over
post-traumatic stress disorder let's say
they were violently sexually assaulted
but it was a while back
and they're still having recurrent
nightmares about that it's still really
really disturbing them one of the things
you have them do is you have to
imagine the assault in as much detail as
they can manage
and the more detail they can imagine
they can imagine it in and the more
upset
they get well they imagine it the faster
they get better
and the longer the recovery lasts that's
something that's really worth knowing
so i suggested to him that when he had a
nightmare that
in the day he remembered the nightmare
voluntarily
so what does that mean it's like well
you know if something frightens you and
you avoid it then what happens is that
when you avoid it you're telling
yourself that that
thing is so frightening that you have to
avoid it and so your brain thinks well
that's a bigger monster than you are
a warrior but then if you think no i'm
going to turn around and face it
whatever it is then you send the reverse
message it's like no matter how terrible
that is
and it can be pretty damn terrible it's
not so terrible that i can't look at it
and so then you get bigger and it gets
smaller and i explained that to him you
know
i said you you concentrate those dreams
are terrible and no one do they disturb
you
you concentrate on bringing them to mind
voluntarily and so what happened was he
started to age in his dreams
took about three months last time i
talked to him he was up to 35 that
happened over about a three month period
and even though he had been stuck that
way for 45 years
you know to turn around and face that
well so that was an example of
let me just look here for a second
if old memories still make you cry it's
an example of
facing things and and and banishing this
and banishing the ghosts from the
shadows
you know so well i didn't really expect
to talk to you only about that new book
tonight but i guess that's what happened
so um
what do i close with
i'll close with what i've observed i
guess over the last year what's been so
cool about all of this you know is that
what have i been trying to do i've been
trying to bring what i knew learned
about
about proper clinical practice in the
deepest sense to as many people as i
could possibly manage you know that's
that's part of that's a reasonable goal
for someone who's a professor an
educator and a clinical psychologist
right it seems like an appropriate thing
to do
you know and the ethos that underlies
twelve rules for life is
i think you would say it's an ethical
it's it's
it's ethical in the fundamental sense i
think it's true that
it's it's better to tell the truth than
it is to lie it's better because
it makes your life better in every
possible way and
and and even more importantly it makes
your life
less horrible so even if it doesn't
bring heaven
on earth to you it might keep hell at
bay and that is really something
and it's really something to know that
it's important to adopt responsibility
that's the one rule i wanted to return
to opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abdicated that's
a
very very cool thing to to know is that
there's a responsibility for setting the
world right that lays all around you and
you can tell that because things bother
you about the world right they prey on
you and
they might even undermine your faith in
existence itself because things aren't
set right you know
but then that's a voice inside of you
that says well there is a right
and things could be set that way because
why would you be bothered otherwise
it wouldn't disturb you but it does
disturb you and it's because
you've got an ethical core and and when
you're disturbed by the fact that things
aren't set right that's actually a call
to you to set them right
it's a call to adventure that's a call
to opportunity
you know i've been talking to people all
over the world about that and people
respond very positively to that because
well i guess it isn't something that
we've been very good at articulating
you know the world's a mess in all sorts
of ways and it disturbs us deeply
and it's easy for us to turn away from
that and it's easy to become cynical and
bitter and then
worse but it's not the right approach
the right approach is to think oh look
i've noticed that things aren't right
and it's bothering me you know enough to
undermine me it's like what should i do
about that it's like well maybe i should
do something about it
maybe that's the fact that my conscience
is bothered
my sense of propriety my sense of
functioning properly in the world is
disturbed by my observation that
things aren't right is an indication
that
i have an ethical responsibility to do
something about that
why else would it bother me then you
think oh well you know well where's the
meaning in life to be found
if there's a meaning in life where is it
to be found well maybe that's where it's
to be found it's like it's to be found
in
the responsibility that manifests itself
when you realize that things are out of
kilt or out of order
and that it bothers you it's like what
bothers you
that's what calls you forward into who
you could be that's what calls you
forward into participating in the
process of setting the world right
and there's meaning in that and and it's
not just psychological meaning you know
it's not just a psychological phenomenon
because it turns out that
you know maybe you're not happy with the
way that your family is constituted in
the way everyone is not getting along
and you decide you're going to do
something about that it makes you feel
better because you're doing something
about it
and great you feel better that's the
psychological meaning but
it's also the case that you are
genuinely a problem solver and it's
possible that you can
help your family communicate better and
then that wouldn't just be a
psychological
improvement that would be an actual
improvement and it does seem to me that
we're capable of actual improvements as
well as psychological improvements and
and if we took our our distaste for the
world
seriously and noticed that that was a
call
from our conscience to action that we
would start to act forthrightly in the
world
and set things right and then the
question would be well
how right could they be set and you know
i said well opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abdicated well
that's
i learned opportunity that's the wind
that blows you into a port
that's what opportunity means that's the
derivation and responsibility is the
wind that blows you into a port
there's things that are crying out to be
done and you know it and it can make you
bitter
it's like no it's like you could do them
you could start doing them you could try
to do them
that would be something god only knows
what you could accomplish
if you did that god only knows what you
could transform yourself into if you did
that
and then that's that seems to me to be
the adventure of life it's like well
who are you exactly well how are you
going to find it out
well take on the responsibility for
making things better
and see how far you can go with that and
you know i've talked to thousands of
people over the last year
it's been so much fun people
after the talks or maybe i meet them on
the street and they say look i've been
trying this i've been trying to tell the
truth or at least not to lie i've been
trying to sort my family out
i've been trying to take on more
responsibility develop a bit of a vision
for my life
a little bit of discipline you know what
it's really working i was in a terribly
dark and black place and i i started to
s
set things straight carefully and things
are way better
it's like well you know maybe that's
true
that'd be so cool if it was true you
know maybe
maybe we have what is necessary within
us to cope with
life no matter how terrible life is and
and not only can we cope with it but we
can actually improve it
and and prove it substantively and
continually and we can find meaning in
that
and we can make things better and so
well that's what i'm hoping will happen
and i think that that's why so many
people are coming to
listen to these talks is because people
have some sense that you know that's a
real possibility that they can
participate in that and that there isn't
anything
better that they could possibly be doing
and so and then i'm hoping that
in this era of unparalleled possibility
that sort of stretches itself out in
front of us now that
if there's enough people who get their
act together you know
as individuals who are each at the
center of the world if enough of us get
our act together then
maybe we can take that tremendous
possibility that's come along with our
technological
what's our technological potency and we
can make things so much better than they
already that we can hardly even imagine
it and
like what the hell that's worth pursuing
man that's worth
that's worth investing in like why not
do that
and so i hope that you do that and i'm
i'm very thankful that
i've had the opportunity to talk to you
about it and and
and it was a pleasure to speak with all
of you so so good night
[Applause]
truly and and i wouldn't lie we've done
100 some odd shows that honestly might
have been the best ending of any of the
shows that we've done
i mean you guys feeling that right now
like
by the way i want to give a quick shout
out i don't know if you saw there was a
young lady
doing sign language right here
[Applause]
that quite possibly might have been the
most difficult hour and a half of sign
language
in the history of the world so you guys
saw multi levels of things right now
so yeah give it up for her
[Applause]
all right so we're going to do a q a you
guys sent in a ton of questions uh
before i do that though
uh where's julia who i was emailing with
today julia
up there somewhere so julia runs an idw
san diego group
and she's inviting all of you guys to
the gaslamp
tavern on fifth after the show maybe
i'll make a guest appearance we'll see
we'll see so uh so check that out after
the show
and uh i should tell you guys this is
actually jordan's computer
and we've gotten close i have the
password he's on twitter right now
i could end it all tonight
ah not tonight jordan peterson everybody
man you were ready to do the last u.s
show tonight huh
yeah i got enough sleep today i guess
and ate enough steak
he's 90 steak people
you want to go to the gas lamp after the
show
with all with all 3 000 of you that
should be fun
all right we got some deep ones we're
gonna go deep down all right
all right are there any topics you
choose to avoid
not really i mean
one one of the i think one of my
peculiarities that's a very long list by
the way
is that i'm willing to have
conversations that other people won't
have
and some of that's really
one of the things i think i've learned
partly from what i've studied but also
partly because of all the work i've done
clinically is that
terrible as it is to have a hard
conversation
the alternative is always worse because
one of the things
that i became convinced of in in my
clinical practice
and my personal life was that no one
ever gets away with anything
ever people think they get away with
things but it's because they are
blind they blind themselves to the
consequences of their actions
you know and so people will come to see
me in the therapeutic
setting and they'll have a problem and
then we'll untangle it you know and
maybe we have to go back 15 or 20 years
to untangle it
and there's there's something back there
that wasn't
an error wasn't always necessarily an
error that they made it might have been
an error that someone else made a moral
error
but there's always something at the
bottom of it and
what's even more horrible is that it's
very frequently the case that what's at
the bottom of it was something that the
person knew was
wrong when they did it and then forgot
and you have to untangle it all and get
right down to the bottom and it's ugly
terrible terrible ugliness at the bottom
you know it's like surgery in some sense
and and you can fix that and those are
horrible conversations
and you really have to pers you have to
pursue the
problem right to the bitter end to un to
undo it
you have to do this in a marriage which
is very difficult thing to do
to make peace and but i know that the
consequence of not doing that is worse
and so even if the conversation is
terribly difficult
it's easier than not having it as hard
as it is
and i guess it's partly because i'm
pessimistic
in in i'm pessimistic
in that i don't believe that there's an
easy out
you either solve the damn problem or it
never goes away
there's this line in the old testament
that the sins of the
fathers will be visited on the sons for
seven generations
it's something like that until you think
god that's not very fair what sort of
you know
who's who set that up it's like
but it's the the truth of the matter is
is that
if you put a twist in the fabric of
reality with deceit you know
with with an immoral action that twist
doesn't
never goes away until someone
straightens it out it stays there and it
causes
trouble it generates catastrophe
and so then you have to go in and sort
it out
as deep you have to go down as deep as
you possibly can and set it right
and then maybe you get some peace that's
a good thing to pursue
it's peace if you can do it but there's
peace doesn't
occur as a consequence of avoiding
you don't get peace by pretending that
you have peace
that doesn't work you get peace by
noticing that you don't have peace
and then doing something about it i
think that's why it said in the new
testament i think that's why christ said
that he came to bring a sword
you know the sword is something that
divides you know it cuts
it judges it it discriminates it
differentiates
and that makes peace you cut away what
isn't
appropriate and you and you dispense
with it and it's painful
but it leaves what's healthy behind
and so no there aren't topics that
that i avoid that doesn't mean that i
would
i'm i'm happy to undertake them you know
it's it's a pain but
it's not as bad as the alternative
period
[Applause]
i like this one what's your plan after
you win this revolution
no pressure
well the win idea is a funny one you
know because
when in implies that you that you're
it implies the defeat of some one
and i gotta think about that for a
second
um there's only one kind of victory i
think
it that's real and that's
that's whatever victory is
part what it's whatever victory there is
in attempting to maintain your integrity
under trying conditions you know
one of the things that that i
decided a long time ago
i i kind of noticed that there were two
ways that you could conduct yourself in
the world i wrote about this in
12 rules for life in in the chapter do
what is meaningful and not what is
expedient
i i learned that you know you can use
your language to craft the outcomes that
you desire and so
if you're talking to someone you can
decide what you want from them
and then you can craft your language to
get that
and then you can call that a victory you
know and i think that's often why
i think a lot of that pathologized your
last
presidential election i think one of the
fundamental faults of hillary clinton
was that
everything she did was crafted for a
particular outcome it's like she wanted
to be president
what do you do if you want to be
president you say everything that you
should say if you want to be president
but then you can't what you say can't be
trusted because
it isn't a representation of the world
it's a
tool to obtain something from the world
it's manipulative
and you might say well it's necessary if
you want to be presidents like well
first of all i don't think it is
necessary second of all it's not obvious
that if you become president
under those circumstances that there's
anything left of you by the time you
become
president right and i think people and
i'm not
and i'm not trying to contrast her
brutally with trump you know
my sense with trump was that people
preferred the unscripted
and impulsive lies of donald trump to
the scripted
and carefully formulated lies of clinton
but there's another way to use your
language and and that way
and that's to just say what you think to
say what you believe to be the case as
carefully as you possibly can and then
to let
the chips fall where they're going to
and i think that's
the right way to live i think that
that's that's the essence of faith
fundamentally
is to believe that truth will prevail
and it's a strange thing to believe
because when you say things that you
believe to be true
the immediate consequence of that might
not be good it can get you in lots of
trouble well everyone knows that that
look why do you lie because telling the
truth will get you in trouble
obviously so you think well i'm not
going to tell the truth it's going to
get me in trouble it's like well yeah
but you think the lie isn't going to get
you in trouble it's like well it's not
going to get in trouble right now
but what about tomorrow and and the next
month in the next year
it's like which of those two things are
you going to trust in the long run
well so i think that like for whatever
victory would
be in this the victory that i would like
to attain in this
in my life would be that i would be able
to say what i believed to be true
and that i could maintain that there's a
great adventure in that
because you don't know what's going to
happen you know you can't predict it
exactly
and it's like it's possible that it'll
be worse than you think it will be but
it's also possible that it'll be much
better and
it isn't necessarily obvious which of
those is more terrifying by the way
because it might be way different at
least than what you were expecting
it's very radical thing to say what you
think and to tell the truth it's an
extraordinarily radical act
and it lays you open to watching how the
world
constructs itself in relationship to the
truth or at least the truth insofar as
you can utter it
you think there's no there's another way
of finding meaning in life is there's no
you know people think they want to have
a meaningful life but meaning is a
terrifying thing it's sort of like
beauty
it can be absolutely overwhelming if you
allow yourself to say what you think you
try to tell the truth you can't predict
the outcome then all sorts of things are
going to aggregate and change around
you and that will be a great adventure
and in that adventure
that's where you'll discover the meaning
of your life
victory for me would to be would be to
be able to do that
you know because i don't think about i
don't think about this as a
i suppose sometimes when i descend so to
speak into the realm of the political
then
things get polarized you know i mean i'm
not happy with the post-modern types and
i don't like the radical leftists
they really disturbed me with their
collectivist viewpoint but but that's
partly because that violates that
principle of
individual autonomy and sovereignty
that's associated with
individual truth i don't think about it
as political i think
i don't think it's political i don't
think of it as political
i think of it as an assault on this more
fundamental way of being
you're an individual you have your
individual truth you need to manifest
that in the world you need to take
responsibility for that
and anything that threatens that i think
is the deepest of threats
and so but victory as far as i'm
concerned would be that
i'm able to
i'm able to say what i i'm able to
continue to say what i think and not be
dissuaded from that
that would be enough and so
so far that seems to be you know knock
on wood
despite all my flaws that seems to be
working out okay so hopefully that will
continue and nothing too catastrophic
will happen
[Applause]
well as long as you mention trump and
clinton this seems like a good segue
will you move to america and run for
president
[Applause]
let's put aside the legal issue for just
a sec
yeah and the possibility of my muslim
birth
you know i've thought about i've been
tempted
let's say by the thought of a political
career
continually throughout my life you know
but
i've never pursued it and it seems to me
rather unlikely that i will
i've talked to my wife about it recently
again not not
in the american context obviously
because that's
well that's obviously
there's you don't think about things
that aren't possible it's it's it's not
useful and um i also not sure that
that's a job that anyone can do
you know i mean it looks like an
impossible job to me
i have a lot of sympathy for the people
who who hold the office because
the responsibility of that office is
just and the complexity is just beyond
imagination you know it's why they get
people who take that job get old so fast
it's no wonder
some of them start out old too
when when push comes to shove i've
always been more interested in this
psychological i'm more individ
interested in the individual
i am more psychologically oriented i
think the
i think my most effective strategy
personally and socially is to
is to operate at the level of the
fortification of the individual
and it's not political there's political
implications of that the political
implications are they are have been for
me is that whenever i see
political occurrences that limit the
degree to which the individual can be
made more effective
then i feel morally compelled to object
to them that's why
i objected to the legislation in canada
it's like
no you don't get to tell me
what i'm going to say i don't care what
your damn reasons are
that's on me what i say
you don't get to decide that for me i
think that you're invading the territory
of my soul
at that point and i don't care if your
reasons are
hypothetical compassion first of all why
should i trust your bloody compassion
it makes you think you're a saint so
you know that's the that's the
suggestion you're so compassionate that
you
get to move my mouth with your hand
it's like no oh that's that's that's on
me
and so that's political action i guess
in some sense but it was
i don't really think it is fundamentally
political because i think that
i undertook it because i believe that
the political
jumped its domain and started to
transgress against things that it should
have left alone
and this whatever we're doing here
together
whatever's manifested itself let's say
in these books that i've written and
the impact that they've had and the
youtube videos and all of that
that seems more it seems more effective
than anything else i can do
you know i'm talking to lots of
political types and that seems okay
but i think that
i think it would be a step
what would he call would be a regressive
step on my part to do that
given the opportunities that i have to
enter the political realm
it's not right and i i don't think i'm
cut out for it either you know like
i don't like conflict
[Music]
i know i know well it's true though like
you know it takes me three days to
recover from one of those contentious
interviews
you know i don't i don't enjoy it at all
i said
at the beginning of this q a that like
there aren't conversations i won't have
but it doesn't mean that i don't find
them stressful
they're stressful and like i'd much
rather have i'd
much rather do this it's much way
more pleasant to come and talk to 3 000
of you than to
talk to one um gq
journalist for 90 minutes
and so i don't think i don't think i
could tolerate that
that political stress you know that that
that
i i don't think i'm cut out for it so
so what you're saying
yeah no kidding he's gonna run for
president everybody
we all heard it so i don't know how this
one
didn't come up in the hundred plus shows
what's your biggest regret in life
i think that i've dealt with most of my
regrets
i i don't think that i'm carrying a lot
of
unresolved past along with me you know i
never really think of the past
i have thought about it a lot i've tried
to
you know there's this
there's this section in the gulag
archipelago
where solzhenitsyn describes
the reconstruction of his spirit in the
work camps and
he undergoes this process of repentance
he he
starts to understand that he's he's had
this terrible
see this terrible sequence of
catastrophes has befallen him
that could easily be laid at the feet of
hitler and stalin
you know and if you need villains those
are those are high quality credible
villains
if you need someone to blame man those
are right at the top of the list of
credible people
to blame and you know he was on the
the russian front in in world war ii and
then thrown into the
work camps by stalin had a very terrible
time of it
but he came to understand that part of
the reason that things had turned out so
badly for him was that he had
compromised his own integrity in all
sorts of ways
over the course of his life and one of
the things he did was to go
over his life he said with a fine
toothed comb
and to figure out and to try to remember
everything that he had done in the past
that
violated his own sense of moral virtue
it's a really interesting exercise you
know
think well you shouldn't do the things
you shouldn't do things that are wrong
it's like okay wrong by whose standards
well you could say well you shouldn't do
things that other people think are wrong
well you could debate that but it's
deeper it's a deeper question is like
well maybe you shouldn't do the things
that you think
are wrong and let's say that you've done
a whole bunch of things in your life
that were wrong
and let's say that you've warped the
fabric of reality
because you've done those things that
were wrong and that if you don't repent
for them and repair them then that then
those then those
errors that you've woven into the fabric
of things they stay
they they stay unrepaired
and so you have to repent and atone
right to use the classical language a
tone means to to become
one again you know and so schnitzel said
that he did that that he
he thought well i can't go back exactly
and rectify the past but maybe i can
make amends in the present
for all the things that i left undone
and i would say that
that i don't i wouldn't say that i have
done that successfully but i could say
that i have tried to do that that i'm
trying to do that and so
i'm atoning for what i regret about the
past by trying to behave
as carefully as i possibly can in the
present
and that seems to be i can't think of
any better thing to do about it than
that
and and so in some sense
the whatever regrets i have are being
yeah i'm atoning for them sufficiently
so that they're not plaguing me
and i'm pleased with when i look at the
my life i'm grateful for it you know
ups and the downs and i think that
well in some sense too i think that it
i'm sort of i'm privileged to atone for
it
that's an interesting thing is that
it's it's really something you have the
opportunity to set what you've done
you have the opportunity to set what
you've done wrong right
you could do that and that is a
privilege
and so it's a privilege to try to do
that i think i could put things right
it's like there isn't a better thing to
there isn't anything better to do than
that
and you can put things right by your own
standards
you know i mean people feel guilty and
that can become pathological you know
you can feel too much guilt you have to
calibrate your guilt you have to have a
dialogue with your conscience
it's not infallible but you do have a
sense of right and wrong
and and and if you followed that sense
and you put things right then
you could find out how right things
could be
and then you wouldn't have you would
dispense with the regret
under those conditions
and you would put things right as well
and then that's what you should do as
far as i can tell
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you